a lot of guys in the league that could
trash talk but it's only certain guys
they're at the top tier then i'm one of
those guys
i like that dude your cousin from boston
look i uh i wrote up a bunch of burns
for you that you might be able to use
to trash talk during the playoffs sure
why not yeah
oh my god wow that was easy great all
right here we go
you're going to need to quarantine 14
days after that travel
now you got that travel quarantine okay
i get where you're going with it
let's try this one okay you like my
uncle with a suspended license
you can't drive i don't get it
yeah as i was saying it it didn't sound
as great anyways
let's move on you must be an anti-vaxxer
with all those
missed shots yeah see that wouldn't work
how about this one
you ride the bench like the judge who
suspended my uncle's license
so you keep going back to the license i
love trash talking guys on the bench but
you gotta know how to trash talk i don't
think talk about somebody's car
and licenses yeah well you couldn't get
drafted in the french army
that's a historical one but it's really
good nothing
that you say is going to compare to even
one thing that i say so how about you're
like my uncle
no not this again listen these are
horrible you probably would have been a
better
mascot than a trash talker but right now
the king is still the king and that's me
come down to the package store someday
and hang out with me we can share with
sam you know
talk like friends do we're not friends
okay but i'm about to head out of here
so all right dude
hey good to hang out hey call me anytime
wow that went really well